i think one of the things that the the
pandemic revealed quite frankly was the
weakness of so many corporate cultures i
mean we're seeing the great resignation
happening and if you read articles or
listen to some of the talking heads you
know the prevailing thought as well
they're getting you know checks from the
government so they're not encouraged to
come back to work um or they're pursuing
their dreams you know which which we've
seen as well in our own company somebody
wants to go be a screenwriter and even
though we have a great relationship and
they love their job they want to pursue
their dreams but the other the other
thing that i think it's is underlying
that it's that it's missing that these
these commentaries are missing is that
um the cultures uh may have been weaker
than we like to think they are um uh
that the the sense of belonging that
people have when they would come to work
is actually a lot a lot more tenuous
than we'd like to believe so the the
bond that's allowing them to go off and
do other things is is easily broken
i think strong cultures when there's a
strong corporate culture we recognize
that i can pursue my dreams and work
because i love it here and i know my
team is supportive of me becoming a
screenwriter or something and i can do
both or even though i'm making money
potentially even more money um there's
so much more i get from my work you know
the camaraderie the love the support i
get all of this training on how to be a
better listener and a better
communicator which is helping me in my
marriage and helping me with my kids and
i don't want to lose that plus i i have
my i have close friends at work um and i
can speak up and say hey i'm i'm being
offered more money from the government
is there anything you can help you know
the point is it becomes a conversation
rather than a rather than a resignation
so i think one of the things that we're
missing is this might be a wake-up call
for a lot of companies that our cultures
are just not as strong as we think they
are you know it's been spoken about for
years that millennials you know and now
gen z are just not loyal to work they
bounce around from job year to year to
year well is that them or is that us
maybe if we had stronger cultures they
wouldn't want to leave maybe if we
offered them more than simply financial
incentives for hitting certain numbers
that they'd want to stay maybe if they
felt that they were growing like as
human beings there would be things that
were more appealing to them than simply
simply a bigger paycheck somewhere else
um so i actually think it's it's a it's
a big wake-up call frankly um uh that
that we we should go back and look at
our cultures and say are we are we as
good as we think we are